so what would be a number that labor
would be content with on the migration
well we don't we're not going to offer a
Target or offer a particular number with
respect to migration I think the speech
yesterday from the Home Secretary
criticizing the policies of the Home
Secretary and the Tory government was
extraordinary this kind of let them pick
fruit uh message we've definitely got
labor shortages in the economy and this
morning we've got the unemployment stats
again unemployment has gone up vacancies
have gone down a bit but employment
overall is lower than it was
pre-pandemic but really worrying it
there's 2.6 million people now that's a
record out of work for reasons of
sickness that's a reflection of the
desperate state of our NHS but we also
know from surveys that many of those
people would return to work with the
right type of help so I proposed welfare
reforms to the benefit system to give
people an into work guarantee but also I
put forward proposals to change the way
in which we give people employment
support in this country bring together
health services and employment job
center services to give people the real
tailored help and confidence to move
into a good page job so I'm proposing
changes to actually get Britain working
again to get people back into work I'm
not satisfied with leaving people on the
margins as the conservatives are would
you change the immigration rules so that
workers in Europe can come to the UK so
that we don't see fruits Etc rotting in
the field well we've proposed a
points-based system to the immigration
the immigration system you are going to
have immigration as part of your mix we
know for example that our social care
sector uh desperately short of people
that's always relied on International
recruitment same with our NHS but what
we should also be doing is investing in
skills and training but what about those
School workers coming to do those jobs
don't want to do well the NHS and the
social Care System look we've put
forward in lower party a really
substantial set of policies to train the
next generation of nurses Healthcare
assistants paramedics midwives and
doctors so we can rebuild our NHS so we
can put so we can get the doctors and
nurses on the front line and our young
people that's a great opportunity for
our young people in this country and I
think you've got to be ambitious for the
country I love this country and you've
got to be ambitious for the people of
this country and I think messages that
are coming out from this this Tory
conference that we're seeing over these
last couple of days where you've got
Tori MPS using uh you know phrases which
are usually associated with
anti-Semitism you've got that guy Andrew
bridge and turning up who got kicked out
of the Tory party you've got Tori saying
expanding Child Care is unconservative
well Rishi sunak's got to condemn this
conference and if he doesn't condemn
this conference and those who've
attended it I think you can conclude
it's the modern face of the Tory party
okay the former Justice secretary sat
where you are at arago said that we
should allow low-skilled workers from
Europe into the country in order to pick
fruit well you're always going to have
you know do you think you're always
going to have
an immigration system which has to be
aligned with the needs of your economy
and that's why it should be point points
based but I'm making an argument that we
should be investing in people with
skills and training and we should be
reforming the benefit system
specifically about unskilled workers
coming in to do those jobs that Brits
don't want to do and if they don't come
in we'll see uh fruit rotting in the
field well to a certain extent you're
going to have people are going to come
to this country and do and do some of
these uh uh do some of these jobs but
I'm making a bigger argument about it at
the moment so they're not allowed to at
the moment well well to a certain extent
you know you're still going to have you
still always going to have
um some of that but fundamentally what
we need to be doing is preparing for the
economy in the future we should be
there's going to be great new jobs in
the future and the green energies in Ai
and I want to be investing in the skills
and the talents of people today to
prepare us for the future but that's not
happening with our welfare system it's
not happening in our job center system I
want to be a welfare reforming work and
pension secretary to change the system
so people's talents can take them as far
as possible do you think that Europeans
who live in the UK and pay taxes in the
UK should be allowed to vote general
election in the UK well they can already
vote for their local general election
their local Council so that has been a
proposal that has been has been well
it's something to be that is getting
looked at uh yeah what do you think well
there's an argument there if someone's
lived here for uh uh 20 30 years and
pays their taxes here and has a family
here their children go to their local
schools there's a there was there was a
an argument as to whether they should
have that right that's something that is
being being looked at well it's worth
looking at it it's something that should
be looked at but it's not a it's not a
you know
um you know a defy a particular policy
that has been put forward but it's
something that should make a big
difference to they become any future
elections well well I don't know about
that is that true I think it would I
think that probably they would be voting
for you rather than for the
conservatives I'm not sure about that I
don't know certainly the youngsters 16
and 17 year olds was it Churchill who
said if you um if you're under 30 and
you vote uh conservative you have no
heart but if you're over 30 you have no
brain uh
[Laughter]
young people vote Labor uh well do they
I mean look I mean I do think there's an
argument for younger people young people
can um uh join the Army and things like
that and they can go to work and pay
their taxes I think there is an argument
for looking again at whether younger
people 16 17 year olds should be able to
vote is something that uh I know when I
talk to younger people that they they
would want to vote and I'll tell you
something if you come to my colleges in
in Leicester and you talk to 16 and 17
year olds they are engaged they've got
strong opinions I wouldn't presume they
would necessarily vote labor by the way
they have very strong opinions about
what the country should and shouldn't be
doing and uh they're very 16 and 17 year
olds in my constituency a very
intelligent young people